it's a rare move from the palace and the
prince the famously private royal issued
a detailed public statement ripping into
the press over their treatment of Megan
Marco and in doing so Harry confirms
he's dead serious about protecting his
girlfriend from the wave of abuse and
harassment that she's endured since
their relationship went public the big
issues racism and sexism from online
trolls and smears against Megan from
tabloid newspapers with racial
undertones the actresses family friends
and ex-boyfriend have also been harassed
on their own doorsteps and badgered to
sell their stories according to Harry
reporters have even attempted to enter
Megan's Toronto home the royal family
and their lawyers have stayed up late
many nights to keep defamatory stories
out of the press
Perry's previous two girlfriends
Cressida and Chelsea had a hard time
being in the spotlight to that degree
it's going to be very difficult to
navigate this relationship and Megan is
gonna have to be extremely resilient the
heartfelt tone is unusual for a royal
press release adding that when it comes
to Megan Harry is worried about miss
Marcal safety and is deeply disappointed
that he has not been able to protect her
he knows commentators will say this is
the price she has to pay and all part of
the game but this is not a game it is
your life and his Megan is gonna have to
be very resilient to the amount of
scrutiny that she's going to come under
it is a level of stardom that nobody not
even a celebrity could really prepare
for